this next speaker
really really loves retro games
and he's the author of the second best
pandas book ever written
please welcome Wes
hi everyone
I'm happy to be here I think this is uh
is there a missing year in the middle of
covet I think maybe this is like year
eight or year nine for me in in a row so
it's been it's been a long time I was
looking back at old old videos old
slides to see how much I've see how much
I've aged so this talk is a little bit
of a a little bit of a retrospective on
projects that I've been working on in my
career things I've been thinking about
so I wanted to share a little bit of
that
um of that with you maybe maybe you'll
find it find it insightful or
interesting
um first I want to just something light
is anyone playing this game right now
like okay it's pretty pretty good game
right like okay
um
so most of you know me from uh
from the pandas project but in in recent
years I've been focused in on the Apache
Aero project and projects in and around
Arrow like like parquet there's another
python project called Ibis that we've
we've been investing in significantly
last few years that you know you kind of
think about as D plier for for python
um
but I just I definitely want to call out
that you know these open source projects
don't
um they they don't happen without
without a great deal of support and so
I'm very grateful for uh all the support
that I I've had over the years from
um you know from from any of these
companies and some that some that that
aren't aren't listed
um you know definitely I think it's
great to see you know our studio posit
expand into building you know tools
infrastructure to support python
developers as well so that we can build
uh you know build better software and
tools for uh for teams that use that use
multiple programming languages
so without the support of these
companies a lot of my open source
projects would not have would not have
been possible and I also want to you
know give a shout out to the to the
pandas Community I think a lot of people
credit me for creating pandas which is
true but I haven't really been deeply
involved in pandas development for about
10 years so the project is 15 years old
for the last 10 years I've been focused
on focused on other projects and in the
meantime there's there's grown a large
community of Open Source developers
around the world thousands of
contributors that have made you know
made this project possible and have made
made it possible for for python to be a
good a good language for for data
science but when I started out things
were you know things were a little bit
different this is a picture of me from
my very first conference talk at pycon
2010 in Atlanta and at that time what I
was you know what I was really concerned
with was you know the opportunity that
that python had to be a first class
language for statistics and and data
science and so I was working to find
collaborators and figure out how we
could you know how we can make that
how we can make that make that possible
and so the first paper that I wrote
about this was
um so we didn't even call it data
science back then it was statistical
Computing so this is from scipy 2010 and
I'm going to point out that
um it's a bit ironic that I am here at
an R conference and Hadley Wickham is in
Austin at scipy so we've we've like I
mean Hadley still is not writing any
python code at all but we've we've
essentially we've we've traded places
but I I think something I think that's
that's telling in a sense that it shows
that that over the years that we we've
had this really fruitful interchange of
ideas you know between these communities
python communities obviously taken a lot
of inspiration from from the art
community I had used R before I got
interested in building tools for Python
and you can see that at that time this
is a quote from the paper so I thought
that there was a great opportunity to
attract users to use Python for
statistical applications and that we
could make make python a good language
and ecosystem for doing
for doing data analysis this was the
moment on Twitter
a little over 12 years ago when I
decided to drop out of grad school and
devote myself full-time to full time to
to working on working on on Python and
pandas
so
so at that time
I was really concerned with you know how
do we get the python Community to work
together to build good end-to-end
solutions that people can use that are
accessible and people can get things get
things done so I wrote this blog post
also nearly 12 years ago so uh July July
2021 and the basic message of this was
there's all these projects and they
don't work well together and this
fragmentation is killing us and I think
that you know with what the arc I think
what we can learn from the python
Community can learn from the r Community
I think that you know R has been really
good at building these like unified
approaches to solving problems like the
the impact of you know the the Tidy
verse on on making R productive for for
data science is uh it was really really
impressive and I think to an extent like
in the python ecosystem we still have a
lot of a lot of fragmentation at the
software level and users are often you
know left with like wow I've got this
huge Smorgasbord of packages to choose
from I just want to you know get
something done and at times and this is
the nature of Open Source software it
can be difficult to know which which
tools to use and you know these days you
know there's multiple data frame
libraries in Python and so a lot of
people are asking me like Wes like
pandas is cool but like should I really
be using polars now or you know there's
other other Alternatives as well
um but at that time you know 2011 2012 I
wrote my book python for data analysis
but these were tools for working with
small data so you might be dealing with
somebody who is an Excel user and they
might be more productive writing code
rather than using using a spreadsheet
and so you know when we were building
these tools we weren't really thinking
about massive you know really massive
big big data sets we were building tools
to empower people to work on data that
fits data that fits on a laptop but at
some point I started working with larger
data sets or building applications we
had um so so Chung my um one of the
early pandas developers we had the
startup data pad we started working on
building a cloud application for
analytics where we needed to have low
latency and work with large data sets
and we started experiencing you know the
pain of scalability and performance in
the in that in that environment so I
gave this talk uh 10 years ago it was
subtitled 10 things 10 Things I Hate
About pandas and so the things that you
know over over that had been about five
years into the experience at that point
and so some of the things that we had
learned well firstly is that a lot of
data analytics problems data frame
problems are very similar to database
database problems and so taking the
approaches and using the tools for
numerical Computing basically what you
would see in Matlab or in projects like
numpy and trying to solve these database
problems led to this this mismatch that
created that created a lot of issues but
to build really high quality database
systems is actually really difficult and
requires specialized skills and know-how
and python in particular lazy evaluate
like the absence of lazy evaluation was
a was a major issue that it made it more
difficult for us to like optimize and
plan queries and do various
optimizations that that would enable us
to generate you know to have more
efficient libraries and I think it's
it's been it's been to see how
non-standard evaluation in R has been
has been leveraged to to do a lot of
magic under the hood to enable
applications to to run faster and we've
we've taken advantage of that in in Aero
land
um in building the building the Aero our
package and integrating with d plier
um but one of the one of the main things
which led to the next kind of was the
segue into the next part of projects
that I worked on was this I the this um
the pain that we saw in plugging
components together composing one system
with another moving date one data set
from one environment to another using
multiple Computing
Computing packages that have different
data representations and we saw that
this was really dragging down the
performance of our systems
so I think this was the first time I
spoke at the New York art conference was
in 2015. so I I was thinking about this
concept of like if there was some way
that we could like decouple the you know
the the data storage like data
representation problem and make that
more modular if we could make the
execution engines like the the
computational systems that power the
data frame libraries and and the data
systems more modular and reusable and
then that would enable people like me
people like Hadley to just focus on
building really high quality user
interfaces that make people more more
productive and so that specialization
and decoupling would be really healthy
for for the ecosystem so I predicted you
know eight years ago that we might be
there by 2025 so I'm happy to say we've
made some progress and so I'm going to
talk a little bit about the ways in
which we've made progress toward that
goal I don't know that we'll entirely be
there by 2025 but we've made material
progress in the last eight years which
has been really exciting writing but
what's Driven some of this this change
and why there's been this kind of
collective uh Awakening to the need to
build
um Next Generation Data Systems is
because Hardware has evolved at a rapid
Pace in in the last 10 years solid state
drives like storage devices have become
orders of magnitude faster memory
networking has become orders of
magnitude faster we have new types of
computing ships
um you know graphical Graphics
processing units which are enabling you
know orders of magnitude more compute
throughput for the same amount of power
so there's all this pressure that's
building up in the system space that's
causing us to have to rethink the
software layer on how we can leverage
all of this rapid change and innovation
in Hardware performance
oops
okay
and so one thing that arose also around
this time that I haven't really been
involved with very much is general
purpose parallel Computing framework so
the ones that are most popular in Python
are the Ray and dasc projects and so
what these projects enabled you to do
was to take python code that runs on one
machine and build a Computing graph that
can be planned and executed with a
scheduler on a cluster of machines so
you're taking your python code that runs
on your laptop and dividing up the
problem into a bunch of small pieces and
then running them on a cluster with one
of these one of these Frameworks
the problem with this approach and there
was a paper also written in 2015 so I
don't know if you're noticing a trend
about like everybody thinking about this
problem at the same time
um is that one of the problem with
general purpose parallel Computing
Frameworks is that they give you
scalability but they introduce a lot of
overhead that's associated with scaling
with scaling out and you introduce a lot
of communication and latency associated
with building distributed systems so
this was a group of researchers from
Microsoft research that wrote a paper
where they examined they examined
distributed systems for solving big data
problems and looking at how much
overhead is introduced in order to
achieve in order to achieve scalability
now it's worth pointing out that
imperfect scalability the ability to
scale is better than not being able to
scale
and so you have a small data problem but
yeah and and that you can work with that
on a laptop but if you have a big data
problem you need to figure out how to
chop it into small pieces and run it and
run it on a cluster
now time has passed and so the
definition of what constitutes small
data now you can get you know servers in
the cloud with 24 terabytes of RAM and
so you know in a sense like a terabyte
of ram in a certain sense could be
considered small data uh when you can
get a server uh server back that big so
so worth uh you know worth keeping in
mind and perfect scalability where you
know going from a problem at size n
versus n times 100
if you need to use a distributed system
to solve that problem you know you're
not going to be able to add 100 have 100
machines and process 100 times as much
data in the same amount of time so you
will pay in order to have in order to
have scalability
so the finding from this paper was
in the published work on Big Data
Systems have great scalability but how
much are the systems really improving
performance as opposed to paralyzing the
overheads that they introduce and so
there's this concept of the
configuration that outperforms a single
thread and so the way I you know kind of
synthesize all this is that not only do
we need to build systems for making
distributed computing easier but we also
have to improve the performance
efficient and efficiency not only of
what we can do on a single machine but
also looking at how we connect machines
together in a distributed system
um so another quote that I like from
this paper is you can have a second
computer once you've shown you know how
to use the first one
so we've been attacking this problem
kind of across multiple fronts and
building some supporting Technologies to
make it more feasible to build practical
real world systems that have these more
beneficial future proof properties of a
lot more efficient a lot more efficient
uh Computing so one of them is the Aero
project which is brought a language
independent Universal I call like a
memory Fabric or a data fabric that
enables us to connect Hardware
programming languages and systems in it
and move data around and compute on it
in different environments a great deal
more efficiently
um so also around the same time this was
in 2017 there was a group in the
Netherlands uh Mark rossfeld and Hannis
mulheisen who wrote about
um the difficulty in getting data out uh
getting data out of database systems and
how databases spend a lot of time
converting data to an immediate
intermediate format to serve it to you
and these ended up being the folks who
created duckdb which is another big part
of the story of how things are changing
in our in our modern times but first a
small a small thing one exciting thing
that's happening more recently in the
Aero ecosystem is some of these offshoot
projects to introduce and push down the
Aero data format directly into database
systems and storage systems that serve
and process data and so so one exciting
thing that just literally just happened
in the last you know month or two we've
been working
collaborating with snowflake you know
for a number of months is that we
natively incorporated the um Aero
database connectivity standard into
into part of snowflake's database driver
stack and we believe that this will be a
blueprint for how modern database
drivers are built enabling applications
like Python and R that speak speak arrow
and have an arrow-based data frame
interface through libraries like d plier
and Ibis to execute much more
efficiently on large quantities of data
that are being exported from a data
warehouse like like snowflake
so kind of the way I think about this is
that this is a quote from Paul Dix it
influx data so when you use Arrow your
data becomes you know becomes your API
so you don't need to think about
converting your data into some
intermediate interface with its own API
so that applications can access it
um so another key part of the story is
this is this concept of modular
programming interfaces so an API that
you use but then under the hood you have
the choice of different back ends that
you can
um that you can select to execute uh to
execute your queries or evaluate your
data frame expression so I would say
that you know dply are really pioneered
pioneered this and I took inspiration
from D plier and starting the Ibis
project in 2015 to do the same to do the
same kind of thing for Python and so
over the course of you know the last
seven or eight years we've been building
lots of back ends and so now dplyer has
back ends from many different database
systems for arrow for duct TB and the
same with Ibis and so that enables you
to write your code once and execute it
on many different back ends another
thing I'm excited about is new
programming languages for describing
complex analytics on data so one project
I encourage you to check out is the
Malawi project which is some the looker
team at Google created this new
programming language and it's the same
kind of concept where you have this high
level interface for describing
analytical queries and it depending on
the database or the backend you're using
it compiles to that of the appropriate
SQL dialect under the hood
um
another big part of the story is this
concept of modular or embeddable query
engines query processing systems so the
two big projects which are going on
actively right now one is duct tbu which
is I know had a big impact in the our
ecosystem in terms of working with you
know very large out-of-core on disk data
sets with SQL and you can use that
through deeply or you can write you can
write SQL queries directly to duckdb
another project is velox which is being
led by developers edmetta who were
initially motivated by accelerating
accelerating Presto DB with columnar
query processing but is since being you
know it's being integrated into a
variety of different Downstream open
source systems and all of this is open
source and so in the past you had all
this Cutting Edge analytic database
processing but it was all happening in
commercial database systems and so as an
open source developer you couldn't just
pick up you know the core functionality
for from redshift or from from vertica
and integrated into your open source
library because it was all closed Source
but now we have these open source
libraries that can be deployed and
integrated very easily into your open
source applications so in the future I
expect that you know it's very easy now
to have high performance Cutting Edge
analytical SQL processing and basically
any application you can run it in the
browser you know compiled via
webassembly like it's it's really
amazing amazing stuff and none of this
existed eight years ago
I think another important Trend which is
going to become more and more important
over the next 10 years is the trend of
Hardware heterogeneous Computing and so
we've seen through projects like Rapids
uh you know led by developers in Nvidia
that we can do efficient analytics and
data frame processing on gpus and
there's another new company modular led
by Chris lattner from the llvm project
which is building a new programming
language Mojo that's built on top of the
mlir compiler framework which is
facilitating you know Hardware
heterogeneous you know running we write
code once and you can compile it and run
it on a variety of different Hardware
devices and get Cutting Edge performance
um so last thing before I I wrap up and
they kick me off the stage
um is to make it easier for all these
disparate systems to talk to each other
we realized that we needed to create
um an intermediate representation like a
language for systems to for data systems
to talk to each other at a low level
without having to get into the the
details of like different SQL dialects
and all of that all of that mess and so
we've been working on some folks um so
my colleagues of Voltron data as well as
a variety of other companies Sundeck and
some others we've been working on this
new project substrate which provides
this intermediate representation
low-level kind of Assembly Language for
data analytic queries so it's a
low-level project most our developers
would never need to know about substrate
but it's uh it's one of these glue
projects that that we think will
simplify and make these systems work a
lot better in the future
so
we need to bend the cost curve to make
to make scalability more affordable in
these systems there's a lot of projects
that are going on right now to enable
that I'm very excited about where we you
know where we are now and where we come
from and
um
so we're doing all these things and for
the Next Generation for the next
generation of data science tools I am
very excited about ending the language
Wars by having the same quality uh same
performance uh and the same underlying
systems running under the hood and all
the languages that we use and I think
eight years ago when I was at the first
New York R conference I was talking
about this and it was it seemed like
kind of a pipe dream at the time but
actually like it's happening it's here
like it's a reality and so I'm very very
excited and that freedom that it gives
developers and users to choose the
language that makes most sense for their
work whether that's python or r or
something else I think that's I think
that's a good thing and we should we
should encourage more of that to happen
um so thanks thanks for listening and uh
I'll be around this afternoon so look
forward to chatting with you thank you
[Applause]